Oh join the bloodbath just walk into a
gangbang do this in my sleep okay I know
I did it help
let's go God watch out for her
let's get home okay watch out for MiG's
okay let's get minx yeah nope didn't do
anything I'm here why do you have a
spear that's not fear I mean you can
choose your weapons when you choose your
class I know I chose thinking for a
reason jeez Meg she touched me again yes
she's crazy
everybody make sure she's actually dead
okay
oh sorry sorry sorry can you heal me
sure she's dead can you use samurai
powers or inhuman or something uh I
could yell at you does that work I feel
a little better thank you oh it's moving
oh jeez I am healing your words I
stabbed minx and it helps
Oh a pink minx it's gonna tie snipers or
something dual wield mine God how did I
change that Oh what is she doing up
there look at Dada
what are you trying to put am i a Viking
or a samurai you're a Viking dual wield
is good well now don't fight me Oh No Oh
miss against me we are not together
against me oh now stop um oh you can
totally be in Jenin yeah and like jump
and shake ah nevermind I lagged in the
air and I fell down watch out watch out
behind you
what how
you go first you go first you go first
okay no we say here we say okay fine you
go first Rado it's a tie-dye sorry no
I'm just kidding no I I don't I don't
I'm not gonna fall for your mix tricks
all right I like are you charging your
attack like three hours before or
something like that
thanks how you doing chop the top oh god
oh my god no no what are you doing
Oh
minx has a pole I've been trying to stab
you for three hours right let me have
another I don't throw [ __ ] at me hey
stop throwing stop crazy by the way you
can tell me one like a cat I don't know
how to find you have an ugly armor I
feel terrible whoa there's a naked guy
in the roof what's he doing he's
throwing spear hide my face oh that's a
real strength
all right here actus bite you traits up
here but I thought you were a friend
enemy worst injury pirate leprechaun
[ __ ] yeah a pirate your moustache is
ugly
that ninja guys really good by the way
it keeps running away from me oh Jesus
Lily just clicking attack I'm sorry okay
I'm not sorry
yeah you need to cut your nails dude
geez oh yeah No why don't you die and so
like it what what happen was a leg
someone joined in the saddle act and you
this teleporting no your head is still
there don't worry
got a crazy person after me are you I'm
gonna get my registry mentally oh yeah
mink so could you we were friends oh
come on you stole my kill you could have
spit on me and I would have died this
game is really good I'm having so much
fun ah
assman got me I try to get ass man I'm
sorry I go what's going to rise ass man
I swear yeah you were to say mama I
think you pledged allegiance to him no
he's ugly mine I wear my stick way
better like I killed him yes for you
okay okay let's hug it out hey nice big
hug v8 and thanks God oh I fell down I
didn't mean to don't kill me I'm trying
to live I want to live I wanna have a
beautiful arm I mean of course of course
please I see you we must get the boot
the boot the boot a Linga how did I can
go fisting nice wait where's my rum
what's that don't hold my crown to that
where's the rum how do I get the rum why
did I do that
yes straight to the point in your checks
come here this is cruel
once I'm done reloading I'm going to
kill oh [ __ ] don't come at me now don't
come at me now together hell yeah that's
good let's get Nate nothing okay oh my
god
he's a trek it's a track I don't have a
ranged weapon they call me a sign all
right that's it
say em nice shot dude nice I stood still
yeah quick before the pyres get to it
Biggs the treasures here I'm dying old
ducks uncle or whatever his name is
oh [ __ ] let me let me drink okay okay
let me drink my alcohol let me drink my
alcohol let's have a bar fisticuffs yeah
yeah yeah you broke my me out stop
breaking my stuff oh let me reload
Leonard
my beard is still beautiful behind you
behind you okay see this like fire in my
face yeah what's going on see people
will fight in here the other two you
have to watch Oh
why did I just walk into a gangbang I'm
trying to kick butt in Maui by the way
I'm gonna die from being kids really get
me kicking me keep picking you guys I'm
ready dad kick I like Viking bullies why
you samurai are how much healthier
happening kick to death
what happens now nice thanks everyone
not everyone lighten up and we'll press
it together okay one two three go and
check okay body eyebrows so if you had
fun watching us play sugary we had a lot
of fun playing it leave a like if you
enjoyed it helps me out a lot and I
really appreciate all of the support
regardless hit subscribe to come to
earth today and asking you in the next
one assassin breath
Adventure